I got some good news for you some bad
news for you about the military in
America the good news is we are so much
nicer in the Army we are no longer mean
challenging people telling them to
toughen up because we care so much about
your well-being but the bad part about
the military is we got weaker matter of
fact here's a recent article that came
from Wall Street Journal stating in 2022
the U.S military had its toughest
recruiting year since we were doing an
all-volunteer military in 1973 here's
the shortfall Army's goal for 2022 for
recruiting was 65 000. they fell short
by 15 000 people that's 23 Navy's goal
was 38 they fell short by 10 000 that's
minus 26 percent Air Force was 27. they
fell short by 3 minus 11 Marines were
the only ones that had a goal and they
hit it and when I share with you the
data today I'll give you one and that's
going to drive you crazy did you know we
spend the same amount of money to
Ukraine already in the fight against
Russia as Russia's entire military
budget was last year wait TC some of
this data you're gonna say what the hell
are we doing in America let's get right
into it
foreign
would say if you give value out of this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel I should probably say if
this thing pisses you off give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
let's get right into a look there's a
lot of things going on right now so well
because recruiting is Downers because
military's gone woke and then Kirby
million blink can say no that's not the
reason there's no real correlation
between the two so we said listen why
don't we look at some of the numbers see
what we kind of noticing that's going on
within our military because Safety and
Security is very important to you too I
I got a family I'm sure you want to be
safe as well so let's see what's really
going on here all right so let's first
take a look at how big our military is
today versus in the past before if you
look at this chart here this goes from
50s till today of course we don't want
to look at World War II because I think
we had a high of 16 million total
obviously some of it you were drafted
you didn't have a choice but I'm looking
at the era that is volunteer air and
slightly prior to that if you look at
this chart in the 50s during Korean War
we had a little over 3 million soldiers
in the military that's between 1950 to
53 a little over 3 million then if you
notice the 70s we went back above 3
million again that's three and a half
million that's the war that was going on
with Vietnam Vietnam
1955-75 and then it dropped off and then
we go into the 80s 90s you're dealing
with the Persian Gulf we had roughly 2
million people in the military and then
today we're the lowest we've ever been
we're at roughly 1.35 million people in
the Air Force Marine Corps Navy and army
combined this is all active duty so you
may say pal I don't know if that's a big
is that a big number compared to what
let's look at a competitors China
China's got 2 million India's Got 1.45
million we have 1.3 million North Korea
is 1.2 million Russia's got 850 000 then
it's Pakistan at 640. Iran's got 575
South Korea's got 555 Vietnam's got 470
and Egypt has 450. by the way for some
of you that want some fun fact type of
thing active and Reserve Vietnam's the
most with around five and a half million
they're really concerned if another
Hiroshima happens again so they want to
make sure they stay paranoid now let's
look at some stats here today nearly 80
percent of all Army recruits have a
family member who serve meanings if I
join maybe it's like my dad served I
want to do the same my uncle sir I want
to do the same at the same time the the
Department of Defense said that 77
percent of American Youth are
disqualified for military due to a lack
of physical fitness low test scores
criminal records including drug use or
other problems so if you don't have that
big of an inventory and they're not
qualified what do you have to do you
either have to keep the standards the
waiters or say well why don't we just
lower the standards to get more people
that get in and then at the same time in
2021 only nine percent of young people
ages 16 to 21 said they would ever
consider joining the military now let's
take a look at what's happened in
America with different policy changes
since 2011 to today 2011. U.S repealed
the don't ask don't tell policy
prohibiting gay recruits from serving
openly in the military 2013 U.S lifts
ban on women serving in combat roles
there's a big thing that happens in 2013
when they said women can go into combat
wait to see the state of here according
to the Center for a new American
Security CNAs the number of women
serving in combat occupations increased
over 60 percent between 2013 to 2018 but
but what else increased let me show you
sexual assault reports made to
Department of Defense skyrocketed right
after 2013. when you look at this here
notice that from 2007 to 2012 it's flat
2013. combat takes place look at the
reports all the way at the top in total
reports from 3 604 reports to next year
5518 and it's climbed all over seven
eight thousand today so you may say wait
a minute so what are you saying you know
that's okay I'm not saying it's okay all
I'm saying is when you send thousands of
men who are 18 to 25 years old with the
testosterone level here and the ratio
for soldiers in active duty not in
combat is for every five male active
duty there's one female so out of six
one is a female five is a male and in
combat the ratios are astronomically
higher you're you're putting these men
in a bad situation but that's an excuse
you're making for them I'm not telling
them don't put people in a bad situation
to do something bad these numbers tell
us it's not a good thing that has
happened again bad policies have
consequences this is showing this was a
bad policy November 2017 this was the
first time the defense health agency
approved payments for sex reassignment
surgery for active duty U.S military
service members matter of fact Pentagon
spent 15 million dollars between 2017 to
2021 treating
1892 transgender troops including 11.5
million dollars for Psychotherapy and
3.1 million dollars for surgeries
according to the defense department data
provided to military.com I want you to
think about in Russia in China in Iran
they're getting a report did you know
America spent 15 million dollars for
surgery Pentagon 1890 what do you think
the enemy's thinking oh my God we're
going to go against transgenders we have
to be very careful because this is like
a level above Navy SEAL or do you think
they're laughing saying what the hell
happened to the most feared military in
the world is that really with the
Pentagon who the hell is running the
Pentagon to prove numbers like this how
would you look at it if the military
said it by the way you can talk about
work policies maybe in business and
other places and sell it in war were
your safeties on the line this sounds
ludicrous to me I don't know if it does
to you as well and so if you're my age
in your 40s you're going to look at this
one and say what are these guys talking
about here but today remember we're
nicer today we're more pleasant today we
we do woosa today in the military and we
do yoga because that's how we defend our
country by being peaceful and telling
the enemy hey China before you kill us
why don't we do yoga together so we can
have more peace what do you think about
that China's going to be like you're out
of your flip of mine Mr enemy boom we
win 2018 big change big policy change
ready harassment prevention and response
in the armed forces policy created under
direction of Defense secretary Jim
Mattis so in 2018 Jim Mattis came up
with a policy here the whole thing was
around anti-bullying policies which he
came up with and they defined bullion as
offensive jokes epithets ridicule or
mockery insults or put Downs displays of
offensive objects or imagery
stereotyping intimidating acts Veil
threats of violence threatening or
provoking remarks slurs derogatory
remarks about a person's accent displays
of racially offensive symbols sounds
like the last dance with the Chicago
Bulls when you play with Michael because
sounds like all that stuff was Michael
doing that when he was challenging his
people and we come the greatest of all
time I understand some of these things
may be harmful hurtful hurt someone's
feelings but you're you're defending a
nation maybe in third grade I understand
these things maybe in fifth grade maybe
in a church okay you can't cross the
line with this stuff but you're being
mentally toughened up to imagine what
the enemy is going to tell you if you
can't take something from a peer how are
you gonna do you see the logic behind or
not the next one I understand
discrimination based on race color
religion sex national origin sexual
orientation but even with that do you
want more women in war in combat than
these are questions we have to be asking
because it's not working and in sexual
unwanted sexual advances requests for
sexual favors offensive comments or
gestures of a sexual nature and then a
couple other things they have here
obviously hazing and retaliation I get
the whole retaliation code red you know
you can't handle the truth totally get
it now all that stuff is fine but let's
see what this did what was the impact of
this in different services that we have
so now what is the punishment if you do
something like that let me read you
exactly what the punishment was for
doing this number one a court-martial
conviction for hazing can result in a
maximum sentence of one year of
confinement a dishonorable discharge and
forfeiture of all paid and allowances
that's probably going to scare the crap
of half the military leaders saying whoa
I don't even want to deal with the
second one a non-judicial punishment for
hazing can result in a reprimand loss of
rank extra Duty restriction to quarters
or a combination of these punishments a
victim of haze can also file a civil
lawsuit against the perpetrators now you
and I may have a different opinion you
may some of you guys might say Pat
what's wrong with that we should have
that totally fine is it working and if
we're mentally and emotionally preparing
you to do what to go shoot the last shot
and while you're shooting the free throw
the player shouldn't say anything bad to
you because it's going to hurt your
feelings okay fine you want to put that
in your little league do it you think
the enemy is going to go by the same
guideline you think the enemy is going
to be like I can't say bad words about
you you little shorty I can't say
anything bad about you you little fatty
but you think they're going to come at
you and emotionally try to like this is
either gonna work or it's not gonna work
but just think about from the enemy
standpoint the enemy is looking at the
same what a bunch of mentally and
emotionally weak people Americans have
become this next one's pretty wild and
2020 Army replaced a shark attack with
Team events called the Thunder Run
meaning shark attack if you don't know
what they don't say go swimming with
sharks shark attack in the military is
when drill sergeant screaming and
training these faces as they stepped off
the buses ordering them to perform
exercise exercises using loaded duffel
bags I clearly did this in 1997 when the
drill sergeant was hitting me with his
hat go ahead hey private get your duffel
back I remember that drill sergeant were
charged with assessing the trainee's
ability to handle stress single enough
to perceive undesirables by enveloping
them in a manner that emulated a shark
attack so that's what they did before by
the way they replaced that with Thunder
Run which is incredibly nice okay very
nice let me share with you team building
exercises that aims to build trust and
recruits are penalized with physical
exercises instead of getting screamed at
what a what a generous climate to
prepare these young soldiers to protect
our country because the enemy is getting
nicer we have to definitely consider
getting nicer August 2021 The Botch
would draw from Afghanistan we left 80
plus billion dollars of equipment
there's not a big deal we can make that
again and sell it again just come back
guys then in May 13 2021 the woke
recruiting cartoon Emma with two moms I
don't know if you've seen that if you've
not seen it this is when they started
saying we have to kind of inject woke in
military now it's in front of all of us
we're seeing it October 2021 maybe
emotional for some you ready
not a general patent something better
than Patton a four-star transgeneral
imagine when the enemy hears about that
can you imagine she is like guys it's
over we're shivering we're gonna face a
four-star transgeneral this person is
going to have strategies better than
Napoleon better than patent better than
all of these guys combined it's game
over let's just kind of surrender and
say you know what U.S you guys got it
you'll win next November 2021 DOD
mandates covet vaccines for all service
members by 2020 roughly 40 000 National
Guard and 22 000 Reserve soldiers who
refuse to take the vaccine have been cut
off from military benefits according to
the US Army and more than 8 400 service
members were discharged for refusing the
shot April 2023 you ready for this one
Air Force will allow more body fat for
recruits as service struggles to find
new Airmen male recruits are now allowed
to have up to 26 body fat used to be 20
and women are allowed to be 36 percent
body fat it used to be 28 and body fat
so let's talk about the problems why is
only nine percent of kids 16 to 21
thinking about joining the military do
they love their country do they have
pride in America let me share with you
some statistics here here's Americans on
being proud to live in the United States
in 2022 by Generations Baby Boomers 73
percent of boomers are proud to be
Americans Gen X My Generation 54 are
proud Millennials 36 percent are proud
but gen Z only 16 of them are proud to
be Americans by the way who does gen Z
spend a lot of time around schools oh
what are you saying Pat yeah they're in
high school they're they're in middle
school they're in junior high school are
you saying teachers are now proud to be
Americans why else would they not be
proud to be Americans they spend more
time around teachers than they do around
their parents who else would inject not
being proud of being an American mom and
dad mom and dad are working from eight
to six o'clock in the afternoon you know
evening five o'clock and then they come
home and they're watching TV but they're
around teachers all day long saying well
America is not what it used to be
America's capitalist America rich people
and I hate America America sucks that's
why we have these numbers by the way in
China are you ready 2023 Global public
opinion index showed 80 percent of
respondents are honored to be Chinese
and 85 percent often proud of the
country's achievement Russia 67 to 83
percent are proud Iran 67 proud U.S gen
Z 16 proud let me show you this other
charge by statista take a look at this
here the red says extremely proud very
proud and the blue is just extremely
proud okay it used to be 90 in the early
2000s we're at 65 percent and the blue
used to be in the 70 in the early 2000s
we're at the lowest we've ever been 38
is how proud We Are to be American
interesting greatest country in the
world creates tens of millions of jobs
worldwide has done so much good for
society but we're not proud to be
Americans why would anybody join the
military that they're not proud of their
country and who are they spending time
with school teachers who are also not
proud not all of them not all of them
but this ratio only tells us someone's
got influence over them I'm saying
teachers have major influence over this
issue here so this whole thing about
what why would the military go walk
right you would say I understand why
Anheuser-Busch would go woke I
understand why Disney why Netflix stock
market billion dollar companies you know
S P 500 you know BlackRock and these
guys can get a hold of them right I
totally get that but military come on
Pat what are you talking about well
here's some data you need to know about
of what's happened since 2001 till today
Pentagon has spent 15 trillion dollars
let me say that one more time 15
trillion dollars of which 54 that's 8
trillion went to private sector
companies private sector companies
report and are held accountable to who
ESG numbers aren't they oh shoot you're
kidding me now let me go a little deeper
for you if you're liking this stuff
according to DOD today 71 percent of the
U.S military budget goes to private
defense contractors let me give you some
of these numbers here you ready number
one Lockheed Martin 39.2 billion number
two Boeing 23.6 billion number three
Raytheon then General Dynamics then
north of Grumman number six is how the
hell is Pfizer on this list 13.3 billion
for what Pfizer's even making money off
the military for the vaccine then you
got L3 Harris Technologies then it's
Humana then he got Huntington Ingalls
and then number 10 is moderna got 7
billion from who are you serious yes who
controls that the same ESG folks and by
the way you want to look at lobbyists
where they rank how much money they're
spending on this let me just give you
the leaders bulletin on Lobby so what
these guys are doing and FYI you know
how typically it's always been well you
know Republicans are all about the war
and that we can buy Republican Senators
and Republican congressmen and
Republican this but Democrats you know
Democrats they're typically bought by
Pfizer and big Pharma but Republicans in
the military people are buying with
these big military contractors today
both Republicans and Democrats are for
war take a look at this data here so by
the way here's an overview from 2015 to
22 of Defense Aerospace Lobby and it
shows the company's Lockheed Martin
Boeing Northrop Grumman United
Technologies Electro impact then how
much money they give to Dems versus
Republicans do you see that so at the
top of 2015-16 Lockheed was 1-5 to
Democrats 2.2 Republicans
1616-1318 if you notice Republicans were
getting more money even in 2017 and 2018
Republicans were getting more money than
Dems in 2019-2020 still Republicans were
getting more money on the Lockheed
Martin cyber watch who flips Northrop
Grumman gave more money to Dems than it
gave to Republicans and then at the
bottom if you look at Lockheed Martin
2122 more to Democrats north of Grumman
more to Democrats than the smaller ones
they're brought even to each other but
Democrats are not getting more money
from Lockheed Martin and Northrop
Grumman than Republicans are we've
always been told Pat Democrats are not
for war but not according to the money
that's being given to the Dems today
maybe parties have changed a little bit
let's talk about solution remember
earlier I said you know if this thing
pisses you off give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel are you pissed
off yet but let me give you the solution
right so for me here's where the buck
stops where the problem is what happens
have you ever had a job when you went to
orientation or have you gone to college
when you go to an orientation or have
you ever played for a sports team and
you got to order or joined the church
and you go to orientation 101 what do
they sell you they sell you the company
wow you know let me tell you Xerox was
first founded in companies and was
hallowed and the founder was this and
our pride in the company is this you
work at Apple Steve Jobs and Steve
woznak had an idea back in 1976 when
they noticed Bill Gates was doing this
man they said they're going to build a
computer the PC personal computer oh wow
what a great history and Notre Dame is
known for it before Lou Holtz another
the New York Yankees George Steinbrenner
and Babe Ruth and man I'm so proud to be
a Yankee every school year should start
with every teacher in every class for
the entire week selling America on on
why it's the greatest country in the
world every kid in orientation first
week needs to be sold on the greatness
of America the positive impact it's had
in the world where you and I whatever
religion we are whatever color we are
whatever part of the world we are we can
coexist you like the Red Sox I like the
Yankees you like the Lakers I like the
Clippers you're a Muslim I'm a Christian
you're an atheist I'm a Scientologist it
doesn't matter we can coexist because
this is the greatest country in the
world where 40 million immigrants are
here they can go to any other country in
the world they can go to China they can
go to India they can go to Russia they
can go to Iran they can go to Colombia
they can go to Cuba they can go to
Venezuela they can go to Germany but
they chose America why did you choose
America it's on an island of its own you
gotta fly from China to come you got to
fly from Middle East to come you got to
fly from Europe to come here why are you
coming here why don't you go through the
surrounding countries because this is
the greatest country in the world and we
have to be proud when I joined the army
I'll never forget I'm in Fort Jackson
South Carolina I joined April 15th of
1997. Memorial Day came I'm in formation
looking at grown men and women E8
sergeant majors first sergeant E8
captains Colonels generals tears and
we're looking at them proud to be an
American they sold you on the greatness
of this country and you have to be proud
about it if we do that kids are going to
say I love America I love America I love
America Prime Star said when we took out
the Pledge of Allegiance last one was
June you know what we do in America in
June pride month what do you see
everywhere you see the rainbow flag
everywhere for the entire month we
dedicate to a small community an entire
month but the majority of Americans get
one day and that's Fourth of July what
no pride month to celebrate maybe a
community maybe a day maybe a half a day
proud to be an American every day every
day you and I need to be proud to be
Americans not one day every day we need
to sell our story to the kids early on I
definitely don't think we're doing that
my second concern is I don't know how we
do this but companies that are able to
leverage the military to make a lot of
money and they get the government
contracts north of Grumman rate down all
this stuff they have to be either
excluded from ESG guidelines because
then that officially means that
BlackRock Vanguard and State Street are
running the military who the hell are
you to be you officially are more
powerful than a commander-in-chief what
are we talking about here no stay out of
this business this is none of your
business okay we're trying to protect
the average American's house and make
sure we keep their freedoms ESG has no
place in the military zero place in the
military we have to keep that outside of
the military you go screw up as many
Fortune 500 companies you want to do
okay because long term everyone's going
to realize your philosophies don't work
okay even Larry Fink recently said ESG
has been weaponized we have to change
the word to something else esg's not
been weaponized you've weaponized ESU
against the American people not the
American people and the critics using
the word ESG as a way to weaponize
against you who the hell are you an 11
trillion auto company to tell American
people we're weaponizing against you
you're doing it to the American people
and they're sick of it simple military
there is no place in the Su in the
military next one I'm like as a
financial advice I've been a financial
advisor since the day before 9 11. I got
my series seven in November of 2001 and
so I've been sitting with clients so you
have to look at our balance sheet
families numbers what they're looking at
what are you spending what's coming in
income outflow all that stuff so U.S is
spending last year 801 billion dollars
in the military number two is China 293
then it's India 76 less than a tenth of
what U.S spends UK 68 billion Russia
65.9 annual Russia 65.9 we sent 66
billion to Ukraine while Russia's annual
is 60 do you you track and this is like
weird stuff right France 55.6 Germany
around the same Saudi 56 around the same
Japan 54 South Korea 50. what the hell
are we doing with this 801 billion
dollars going to where's the
accountability with this guys I'm a
pro-military guy I'm a pro-second
Amendment guy but what do we what are we
doing with this 801 billion dollars I
think we need to kind of audit and see
where the money's being spent where is
it going to where is the Investments
we're making Is it wise Investments
we're making why do we use the US
dollars to make money for these other
companies 71 it's a little bit
concerning and last but not least
whether you're a Democrat or Republican
if I read structure on what the
Kennedy's family stood for Bush's family
stood for you like one you don't like
the other I don't care I'm just telling
you what these families build from the
top the idea was that there's four ways
to give back to your country number one
is through military number two is
through Public Service politics whatever
you want to get into number three is
through church and number four is to
charity go you know participate and get
involved in a non-profit organizations
this is something where we have to
contribute to what this great nation has
done for us this place was here way
before you and I got here unless if
you're 250 years old and you're not
these 56 men build it and we are the
recipients the beneficiaries of these
incredible policies and this
Constitution and the Bill of Rights we
are the recipients of these 56 men who
were anti-establishment men against
Britain where they said no we want to be
free we want our people to be free so we
went from having 56 men who were
anti-establishment wanting to fight for
the freedom of you and I to not going
back and becoming exactly what we do you
understand what's going on here it's
kind of weird right so if you love
America as much as I do this is when we
got to be a little bit vocal and sell
America to everybody around us tonight
after you watch this video sell it to
your brother to your sister to your
husband to your wife to your co-workers
just go tell them why you love America
so much actually start that tradition
make a video today post it on Instagram
post it on Twitter tag me here's why I
love America and let's start this
tradition going of telling everyone even
if 22 people see it even if 600 people
see it who cares let's tell our story
it's this simple my name is Patrick
David let me tell you why I love America
and post it see if we can create a
movement of why I love America hashtag
and get other people to say wait a
minute you're wrong but America sucks
but America this and we keep saying
here's why I love America here's why I
love America here's what I love America
and that here's why I love America
starts with your family in your house
with your kids with your parents with
your siblings and with your friends I
know earlier I said well if you're
pissed off give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel but if you're
inspired right now give it a thumbs up
subscribe to the channel I got another
video I want you to watch the rise of
weak men in America if you've never seen
it click here to watch it take care
everybody bye-bye bye-bye
[Music]